[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen heute berichte
ich euch über die kennt beckmesser in
dortmund wir sind jetzt schon zum
zweiten mal auf der kirchenbank letztes
jahr war unser erster besuch und vor
wirklich schon eine richtig tolle messe
aber ich glaube das ist dieses jahr
wirklich noch mal viel schöner war vor
allem weil wir natürlich auch jedes
etwas zu lernen
die kegel beckmesser findet immer zwei
tage statt und wir sind natürlich dann
mit dem ganzen team morgens in aller
frühe angereist und haben dann den
kompletten messestand selbst aufgebaut
das ganze ist natürlich ziemlich
anstrengend und wir machen das aber
prinzipiell immer so dass das alles
zusammen aufbauen so weiß einfach jeder
wo was steht und natürlich sind wir
besorgt das gemeinschaftsgefühl finde
ich ganz cool weil der es wirklich
teamwork angesagt und jeder muss auf
jedem hören und allem zusammen arbeiten
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal ein
paar bilder vom aufbau
manchmal entstehen dann natürlich auch
probleme die wir selber nicht
vorhersehen können und ob ich planen
können und es gibt einfach gegebenheiten
die sind einfach so jetzt schaut euch
einfach mal ein bisschen auf eine junge
reyer
[Musik]
also eigentlich sollte er schon direkt
beim aufbau sein aber leider gibt es mal
wieder logistische probleme wir sind in
halles leben darf kein lkw reinfahren
funktioniert nicht deswegen muss jetzt
hier hinter uns abgeladen werden und das
problem das siegel stellen wenn du
hinter uns zu schießen falls binnen zwei
wollen wir zwischen gezeigt wir sind
schon seit 3 uhr heute morgen unterwegs
kamen um fiedler etwa hier an den
dortmund und jetzt schon seit zwei
stunden warum kommt ihr nicht aufbauen
aber ich hoffe dass wir ein problem
gleich lösen kann ich jetzt muss der lkw
aus laden weil einfach direkt vor
unseren hallen vor die steigung zu sehr
ist und da kannst du dir einfach nicht
hinfahren und ausgeladen werden und dann
gespräche und hier raus
[Musik]
ja
jetzt am backen muss immer ein bisschen
was vom bakken vor allem den mini-pc
klima tri den berühmten leckeren
schokoladenkuchen von mir und dem späten
ausgleich 45
aber wir haben jetzt zum 5 der
messestand nicht ganz und ich bin hier
wie gesagt noch weiter backen wir müssen
noch einkaufen wenn ihr es noch nicht da
deswegen werden gleich andreas einkaufen
damit wir über packen können also zum
glück hatten wir mit dem fahrrad mutter
ist zum glück auch gekommen
aber den rest zu holen
[Musik]
mit
wir sind immer ganz vorn abend wenn der
aufbau endlich geschafft ist vom müssten
dann auch gerne abends noch zusammen
einfach ganz gemütlich in den tag
ausklingen zu lassen und um nochmal
kraft über müsse den nächsten tag bei
mir geht es morgens mit der messe dann
immer so viel los dass ich in zwei
stunden formen zu beginn immer schon auf
der messe damit ich auch meine zutaten
vorbereiten kann eventuell noch aus
richtung kamera vor backen kann damit
ich später dann bei der balkon porsche
einfach ganz ganz viel zeit haben für
euch und eure fragen
[Musik]
kurzfristig ist die besucher durften
schon in die halle rein aber zuschlägen
ist wahrscheinlich vor dem rolltor in 15
minuten geht auf hold hoch ich hab ja
alles vorbereitet gemeinsam mit meinem
team geschmissen um eine liste wird
gehen die klimaverhältnisse backen die
die schnecken den zeiger mich
vorbereitet offen gemüse geschnitten so
gut geworfen habe ich vergessen um einen
gott fotografen horas bringt mich um
egal ob man es gleich los vergeht zeit
gerichtet lang abgekocht abschnitten uns
eingelegt ich glaube es kann losgehen
hier steckt noch ein bisschen zeit
ein paar minuten stand die zuschauer da
sind genau 50 und jetzt ja was macht
jetzt lege ich mir meinen hepp verdammt
und meine schiffe genau mein lippenstift
nach und dann fahr ich hab gestern
gemacht im backofen egal nächste mal
wohl nur einen mit für olive mit selbst
einige funktionen die man muss mir noch
shoppen macht nichts wir haben es geht
los an der kurzarbeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und auch diesmal war unter zwei jahren
mitarbeiter war in welzow mit dabei auf
der messe und hat seine tolle show
gemacht emmental ist und kann als auch
hypnotisieren
und da habe ich euch auch schon gezeigt
und auch erwähnt dass ich das selbst
glaube um kritisch offen
aber es funktioniert habe ich mich und
jedes mal findet immer wieder verblüfft
weil er immer wir sind wie das sich was
neues einfallen lässt
dieses mal weit sogar weiter hypnose
beteiligt heißt er hat weiß zuschauer
versuchen eben gesagt ihr fallt in der
tiefe hypnose sobald die fälle euch
verführt und dann orte vor allem
unglaubliches gefühl
also darf selber ebenso daran beteiligt
zu fallen und dann stehen die wirklich
tag waren sie einfach weg fast alles
raus im jahr war dass ich echt immer was
neues einfallen und ist natürlich immer
ganz schön weil sich eben für den pfad
packen und kochen zuständig für den
fragen beantworten ja findet natürlich
darf für die unterhaltung unterstützt
mich auch sehr gut dabei und bei ihnen
könnt ihr auch gerne mal auf dem youtube
hat und auf der facebook leider vorbei
schauen und wir werden sogar mit ihm
demnächst einen weltrekordversuch machen
da bin ich dann mit dabei da werden dann
kam ich über 300 leute gleichzeitig
vorsprung und da gibt es einfach
verschiedene workshops die machen wir es
auch demnächst mit meinem team und dann
wird ab in den weltrekordversuch mit auf
14 durch ko jedes jahr war auch in
dortmund auch wieder ein anderer freund
von uns dabei und vereidigter markt
winkeln die auch bereits auf vielen
verschiedenen videos den kennt ihr
vielleicht von coop aussehen
der ist nämlich von koch blumen machte
auch keine vorführungen und es ist
wirklich ein super guter freund von uns
und den seen mir privat auch über ganz
auf und dann wird natürlich immer
richtig lustig weil der flug hat nichts
an stellt ich praktisch wird der
betreuer von moral und die zwei machen
das hat immer gegenseitig fertig und das
ist echt super witzig aber das wissen
sie lieben sich heiß und innig
[Musik]
wie einfach schön nach der messe ist vor
der messe war schon eine messepark
hinter uns gebracht um heute steht
webseite und leider auch schon letzter
messetag vor uns und ich komme irgendwie
gar nicht dazu euch auch die ganze messe
zu zeigen auch mal dahin weekend weg zu
zeigen weil einfach so voll ist und ich
wirklich mal eine pause habe ich fünf
minuten aber muss man schnell wieder
hier vorne stehen entweder in der krise
oder autogramm stunde
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal kurz
vor der anstrengung gleich wieder los
gibt meinen messestand während murat
fleißig hinter mir ein bisschen den
boden gleich einen richtig leckeren
cappuccino raus oder alkohol ich habe
einfach das beste team oder dem ersten
preis und zwar habe ich hier den
kernbereich also hier finden praktisch
die küchenmaschinen und meine zuschauer
und besucher die können ja herkommen
oder ihr könnt ihr hier her kommen und
euch hier beraten lassen
danielsson da das ist unsere fachpartner
seit über 100 jahren und da hat es echt
gut gehalten sieht echt gut aus und noch
sehr jung und hier ist dann auch noch
der christian mit dabei und wie beiden
sind einfach die experten kennen sich
hier aus und können einfach beraten weil
ich eben jetzt hier in der küche die
zeit nicht das verfahren dann seht ihr
direkt nebendran meine küche das team
jetzt grad andrea und sabine hallo
gemüse für die tour ist um einen kuchen
und dann einfach später ein bisschen
schneller was und können dann eben
schnell backen und kochen und hier in
der küche wird er auch 4 2 führung und
auch gleich hier über euch zwei
bildschirme damit einfach die zuschauer
auch hinten was sehen können den
messestand von merz schon seit über
einem jahr
und der hat uns ja auch echt immer treu
begleitet aber wir müssen demnächst nach
einem neuen messestand schauen weil dann
natürlich auch immer ein bisschen
mitgenommen wird damit waffen älter mit
drauf dann wieder runter aufgebaut
abgebaut werden und es ist natürlich für
uns ganz neu land also wir haben ja
vorher alles nicht und muss man dass ich
erst mal
wacken und wieder keine professionellen
messebauer von der wibag improvisierte
messebauer und haben uns natürlich alles
erst einmal lernen müssen
das heißt der nächste mittelstand muss
einfach noch ein bisschen stabiler
gebaut werden größer gebaut werden weil
die füße für mich alleine war
aber wenn jetzt bei murat noch dabei ist
unser markt unter jahr sind zum beispiel
ist es einfach ein bisschen zu klein
was ich ganz gut finde was aber vor und
machte gleichzeitig ist wird auf jeden
fall auf augenhöhe sein mit wein zu
schauen keine extra bühne haben wenn ich
einfach so schöner sonst nicht mit allen
für unterhalten
das sieht man einfach da kann sich die
auf uns schauen die kinder sehen mich
vor allem aber das problem ist die
hinteren sehen uns nicht so gut und
deswegen haben wir eben hier oben auch
die monitore und da ist und alles schön
groß zu sehen
denk mal kurz in die kamera da oben
sabine mal da oben in die kamera genau
dann geht's weiter hier auf der linken
seite haben wir dann den kitt bereich
das ist natürlich schön bunt und ihr
steht dann der benni abwechselnden im
saal der gaststätte wallstreet einfach
für kinofilme und dann beraten die eben
hier auch und hier gibt es noch diese
ganze farbvielfalt das heißt hat man
viel zu sehen viele zum ausprobieren
wir kennen ihn vielleicht auch von den
facebook gruppen zum beispiel mit zwei
kinder bin ja was haben wir hier noch
und dann geht's hier weiter zu meinem
job du bist wer bereich von meinem stand
stehen ist eigentlich nur beim auf und
abbau sehen denn während der messe habe
ich da eigentlich gar keine zeit dafür
ich hab auch werden denn es wird keine
zeit darüber zu gucken und wir haben den
job wirklich auch schon sehr vergrößert
von der fläche her damit einfach nicht
so eng alles ist und wir sind wirklich
mit 22 mann auf der messe und wirklich
ein sehr großes team aber natürlich hat
man trotzdem ein bisschen wartezeiten
obwohl wir immer schauen dass wir alles
optimieren also wirklich kassensystem
ist top und dann zum anschwellen und es
ist wirklich alles super optimiert es
geht natürlich immer noch größer aber
man muss natürlich das ganze auch immer
finanzieren können und was man sich ganz
wichtig ist auf der messe das eben auch
sponsor mit dabei sind ohne geht es ganz
einfach nicht zu tragen werde ich habe
viele viele sponsoren hiermit auf der
messe gezeigt aber gleich
und hier sehen wir jetzt direkt in der
versuchsküche die haben jetzt vier meter
tiefer aufgebaut und hier wird einfach
gezeigt dass qualität ist und was
vielleicht nicht so gute qualität ist
das heißt wir haben meine besucher
einfach mal die möglichkeit die sachen
in die hand zu nehmen
zuschauen menschenköpfe die sind dann
wirklich verstehen auch mein 2% auf kuba
und einfach auf alle anderen dinge die
wir eben auch im shop anbieten wird man
einfach wirklich die möglichkeit auch
mal dinge auszuprobieren und zu
vergleichen und es ist auch wirklich
ganz schön wie drüben zum beispiel
gibt's dann die torten red haben und
hier zeigen wir den unterschied dass
eben meine torte zwar auf edelstahl
stehen das heißt sie kann man auch
einfach in die spülmaschine stecken
früher haben wir die torten retter aus
aluminium von anderen herstellern und
sie verfärben sich einfach in der
spülmaschine weil sie eben nicht
spülmaschinen geeignet sind und es wird
einfach hier an diesem stand gezeigt und
da haben wir auch immer die kleine
schilder da steht dann eben auch darauf
dass unsere produkte zu 100 prozent aus
deutschland sind bzw ein produkt aus
frankreich ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben aber zum beispiel auch ein
paar andere küchenmaschinen wie zum
beispiel im discounter gibt und hier
sieht man einfach dass zum beispiel
diese kühl die maschine mit einem arm
hochnehmen 11 tatsächlich kein gewicht
da für uns in die saugnäpfe hier können
auch die besucher einfach mal
ausprobieren und aufsätzen und einfach
aussehen warum ich eben fantasy
hochwertige produkte belasten
jetzt nehme ich euch mal mit in wien
wächst ist bereits hier haben wir unser
shop lager und wir haben sie haben dann
immer alles gelagert können auch die
kartons entsorgen und hier zum beispiel
sondern auch um verschwundene worden
ich habe hier zum beispiel an die
flaggen von küchen gibt es daneben für
meine zuschauer
die dürfen wir dann kaufen luft
verteilen oder auch jedes globus mir
gestern schon zwei volle paletten
verteilt da stehen man inzwischen hat
sich total auf einmal in videos genutzt
und immer gefragt werden entfällt das
ist ein tolles mail
und dann haben einfach vom globus
angefragt und sie haben uns dann einfach
ein paar paletten geschickt ansonsten
ist mir glaube ich schon gefunden so
leergut wirklich nicht so schön
hier bereits wieder im shopbereich
haushalts zb und kenne ich auch schon
seit ein paar jahren und sieht dafür
deko back und zeigt euch mal was vor
ihren stand machte spaß bei uns auf
jeden fall
und welche chancen jetzt mal hier macht
sie dann ihre vorführungen das heißt
hier zeigt sie immer mit fonda
modelliermasse modelle schokolade und
überhaupt orten oder kuchen dekorationen
umgeht
da kann man hier ihre fertigen torten
anschauen echt voll schön oder da unten
mit den blumen und hier dürfen einfach
die zuschauer und besucher sie mit
fragen durchlöchern bin ich mal gespannt
was heute alles entsteht jetzt den
fleißigen shop helfen
hier sehe ich schon beim vorbereiten
ja genau und hier warten musste dem
produktkatalog dem neuen ressort recht
zuvor geworden und sagt können sich
zuschauer und besucher war das einfach
mitnehmen
im onlineshop gibt es ihn dann auf und
muss kindern einfach nicht noch nicht
alle fotos drin aber zunächst mal ein
paar schön handlich und ich sind für
online shop immer ganz schön aber ich
bin doch ganz schön wenn man so dastehen
kann um zu klettern kann
durchstöbern kann
hier aber zum beispiel eine
pflegehelferin und seilen hat mich in
köln auf der livingkitchen das erste mal
besucht und da war sie ganz verblüfft
dass ich sie erkannt habe an ihrem namen
und zwar deswegen weil du immer so
kommentiert auf facebook einfach die
tore ganz toll zuschauerin und sie hilft
uns eben die zwei tage jetzt hier auf
der messe und es echt folge aber
anstrengenden tag später zum beispiel
haben wir dann den ausgangspunkten
bereits was fehlt von gross und leer
ausgeht später wirklich alle voll und
einfach geschaut wird uns großzügig
wählen damit wir einfach die schlange
und koordinieren und ordnen können und
die zuschauer einfach nicht zu eng
beieinander stehen weil so eine messe
hat natürlich thematisiert aber trotzdem
irgendwie einfach die luft in der halle
und wenn man sich doch warum sind frei
bewegen kann
[Musik]
dieses jahr hatten wir sogar richtig
denn es kamen ein paar mädels vorbei die
verfolge ich hoffe auf instagram dass
nämlich die fans genauso auf wie ich
kann auch dann ihren tausenden und
dieses jahr abschliessen
alle zu bekommen aber die powell hatte
bei den viel mehr und sie kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch wird ja auch einen
youtube-kanal selina war dabei joline
diana nicole di anima dabei und ich
hoffe ich habe es einfach niemand
wichtigen vergessen und die haben dann
mitgeholfen getränke zu verteilen haben
sich wirklich super um eine besucher
gekümmert
es war so lieb und ich glaube das werden
wir jetzt auf den nächsten müssen auch
so machen wenn man einfach ein paar
freiwillige helfer kommen die dann eben
den tag mit uns verbringen dürfen und
war echt super schön vor allem denke ich
dass ich wirklich jeder besucher gut
aufgehoben gefühlt hat und einfach auch
gut versorgt wurde
aber insgesamt kann ich sagen dass es
wirklich eine wunderschöne messe war
wirklich ganz toll samstag und auch der
sonntag war richtig schön und ich kann
mich nur bei all unseren besuchern
bedanken die wirklich da waren viele
haben auch ganz lange anfahrtswege
wieder auf sich genommen und mit uns den
tag oder das ganze woche in der tat zu
verbringen
ganz herzlich will ihn natürlich auch
bei den sponsoren bedanken die eben
alles ermöglichen damit ich meine
zuschauer und meine besucher eben auch
immer ganz toll bewirken kann
vielen dank auch an alle helfer an liegt
ganz tolle mädels gruppe an mein ganzes
team und ja wirklich super schön und ich
freue mich jetzt auch schon auf die
nächste messe jetzt gibt es erstmal eine
kleine sommerpause
und dann geht im september auch schon
wieder los mit der baden messe die wir
dann in freiburg stattfinden
klasse gibt es aber zeit natürlich auch
noch mal ein video und ihr könnt auch
immer auf meiner webseite vorbeischauen
da gibt's auch immer alle informationen
und sie haben ich muss jetzt erst einmal
wieder das ganze video material
anschauen ich finde es immer wieder
schön auch noch mal rückblickend
alle bilder von der messe zu sehen weil
es einfach immer ganz tolle tage sind
auch sehr anstrengend wurde schon
zugeben aber wirklich immer ganz schön
also vielen dank fürs zuschauen vielen
längst besuchen und wir sehen uns dann
wieder von nicht normalen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kaum freuen
[Musik]
ein
am 1
[Musik]
b
mehr
[Musik]
ein
und dieses mal war auch wieder jahr sind
mit dabei denn kennt ihr vielleicht auch
auf meinem besser mails video besser
menschen besser
[Musik]
mit einem happy end hoffen
das ist die vorspeise haben wir gleich
magdeburg wenn ich auf die letzten paar
tage kein keine einzige wurst gegessen
deswegen bereiten wir die mit meyer und
ja
[Musik]
mehr
laumann
wer wisse schon vorbei mit zwei zungen
beim av die mädels nicht die eier und
diana wissen wir fleißig am kochen und
backen slam wie andrea führen zu einem
aufräumen und wie ihr bereitet von bis
zu erstens vorsitzteam
wie geht das leckere wurst komme ich
hoffe ich mache genau so gut wie er
und dann warten teams ist gleich hier
die stärkung holen die ersten dann
zusammen und dann gefreiter und denke
wir werden heute bestimmt auch für
setzte eine kommission von gebrauchen
und dann sind wir alle fix und fertig
aber eine tolle messe
[Musik]
da
[Applaus]
[Musik]